we normally start in the dark
and then begin by carving out to bring
the audience's attention to one thing at
a time
how do you give physical concrete form
to something as abstract and nebulous as
music or to an idea
when i was at school my teachers called
me a jack of all trades master of none
the more paths i was offered the more i
wanted to take i wanted to read about
neuroscience and eco-psychology i
studied english literature then art then
stage design
it's quite unusual to make that leap
from classical theater into pop music
and people are constantly invited to
specialise and i'm here to teach you to
do the opposite
[Music]
this class is for those
who want to turn what is in their mind
into something they can hold in their
hand whether it's within the field you
currently work or specifically within
the field of design
iterate iterate iterate even when you
think you've arrived at something and
you might even just
infuriate yourself
into having to come up with a new idea
so many artists designers makers once
you peel away the surface you realize
that they're making in order to conquer
a sense of loss and certainly in my
experience i made a decision to throw
myself into my work
in my early 20s because of a loss that
happened in my life
that energy of creation
as a reaction against loss
is incredibly powerful
you have never researched enough
your life will be
an endless
and i hope fruitful and happy journey of
not knowing enough
if you're choosing to watch this class
because you want to keep expanding the
paths along which you walk
you're in good
company i am s devlin and this is my
masterclass
[Music]
so
[Music]
you